In our final chapter here, let's look at some optimization tools.
So first we'll talk about some UMG.
This command will make it so that UMG widgets are only redrawn if and when they are changed
or updated.
So the command is enabled by doing the following and number one is enabled.
So this slight enable global validation, invalidation.
If you have space number one, it will enable it and zero will disable.
So you can see the result of this when you have to do the following.
So if we run the game in a new editor window, which is very important, don't just play in
play in editor as part of the viewport there because you'll be rendering the editor as
well as your project.
So run the game in a new editor window, super important.
Enable the stat slate.
So open your console by pressing the tilde key and type stat slate and then input the
command and watch the numbers.
So this is a good one for UMG.
We also want to check it on the device.
So PC is great for emulation, but you'll always want to check on your target device.
So the PC will give you a rough estimation of what's going on, but it's not going to
be true for your project on that specific platform.
So especially in HMI, check early and check often.
We also have a tool called size map, which you can right click and find in this property
here.
Size map, you can also see the console shortcut alt shift and M and the size map will show
you the size of the selected asset, including anything that it's linked to.
So it's a visual representation and it really helps narrow down really large assets.
So the tool will tell you both the size on disk and then also the memory and asset or
groups will take up.
So that's really useful when trying to optimize the package content there.
Next we have statistics.
So in our level editor window, we can also see statistics there and this window will
break down the number of assets in our level files.
So we can display that either on all levels or only specific levels.
And the primitive stats information on the list here is about the number of triangles
and memory consumption and count.
So other data that's displayed on this list include things like texture usage and static
mesh lighting information.
But this window can quickly illustrate which assets are consuming the most memory.
So it's definitely worth looking at this when looking to optimize your projects.
There's also a merge actor tool inside of Unreal Engine.
So when we're looking at the merge actor tool, it's just a way to combine multiple
meshes into one static mesh and one material.
So the tool will take all of the selected meshes and materials and merge them into a
mesh and into one material.
So you used to have to do this inside your DCC, but you don't need to do that anymore.
You can do it inside of Unreal Engine, which makes it way less time consuming and doing
it will reduce the amount of draw calls, as we were speaking about before in reference
to draw calls.
It just makes things cheaper to render, which is especially important for especially things
like VR and mobile applications.
So each material is an object, which means that it has to be rendered each time.
And so an object with three materials will be rendered a minimum of three times, which
is why you want to reduce as many draw calls as you can.
So this tool will take all your selected static meshes and materials.
It'll create an atlas out of them, reducing it down into one mesh with one material.
So how this tool works depends on your content setup.
So content, you know, as long as it's all set up in the zero to one UV space, that will
help it work better.
Assets that use world position offset or world based texturing will not bake down correctly.
And then also, if you don't like the results, try using something like a substance pater
to combine the meshes.
So an external DCC you might have better mileage with as well.
So let's look at some of the settings of the Merge Actor tool.
So it's found by going to Window, Developer Tools, Merge Actor.
And again, if you just click Window and type in what you're looking for, it'll automatically
select the pane as well that you're wanting to open.
So you'll need to do a few things here.
We want to make sure the Merge Actor tool is open.
Then select all the items we want to merge into one static mesh.
Make sure that the following options are checked.
So we've got on the bottom here, we've got pivot point at zero.
We've got Merge Physics Data and also Generate Lightmap UV.
We also want to set the LOD selection type to use a specific LOD level.
And then in the materials, we want to set the texture size to 2048 by 2048.
We want to size the type to use bias based on the texture size.
And then also enable all the maps we have.
So check replace source actors and then press the Merge Actors button.
And then tool can take anywhere between a few seconds to a few minutes, depending on
what you're trying to merge.
And it depends what you had selected.
And you should do this at the end of your project right after you've completed all the
content and you're happy with the layout because if you need to redo it, that can be the most
time consuming to redo.
And another tool we can make use of is the Memory Parting Tool.
So this is another console command.
So you use a tilde key in your project editor and then you can type memory part dash full.
And it provides a closer look at the memory usage on devices.
So once the app is built in the development configuration and is loaded to the device
that you can use the console command on, if you're using an Android device, it's four
finger press on the Android to open the console.
And then you can just enter this console command and it's essentially a memory snapshot, which
is saved into the projects directory on the device.
So usually it'll be something like, you know, UE5 game dash your app dash your app dash
saved dash profile in dash memory ports.
You'll likely find it somewhere in that directory.
So again, it's in your app, saved, profiling, memory ports.
So if you search the term listing all textures, you will find a list of each and every texture
used along with detailed information about the texture type, the group size and the memory
footprint and the larger textures are represented first, which is quite handy there.
So it's a quick and easy way to spot the textures that are costing the most amount of memory
and definitely useful to run on the target platform that you're looking for.
We have a few other stack commands as well, which provide pretty detailed information
on our project.
So there are many more than what's listed here.
A good target of draw calls, for example, in an optimized scene is below a hundred on
something like a Galaxy Tab S6, 50 or less on lower end hardware.
But again, hardware quickly becomes outdated.
So it's best to check what your target for the optimization is and process the scene
based on that.
We've got the StatGPU, StatUnit, StatUnitGraph, StatTextureGroup and StatRHI.
And they're all useful commands to get you going on your journey of optimization.
Looking at PSO caching as well.
So PSO caching is a way to speed up the rendering of your package projects when deployed to
device.
So PSO caching works by first creating a list of all the needed shaders that are required
by the materials that are used in our Unreal project.
And that list is then used to help speed up the compiling process of the shaders when
they are first encountered by our Unreal project.
So in terms help essentially reduce any of the hitches of the project might encounter
when a material requires a new shader to be compiled.
So PSO caching doesn't require our artwork to be set or created in a specific way.
It's just something that is enabled at build time.
And so because of this, setting up PSO caching can be a complex process that is generally
best handled by a programmer or an advanced technical artist.
It's important to know about these as it greatly helps load times and reduces hitches.
But if you want to know more about PSO caching, there's some great documentation.
So if you just type in on Google Unreal Engine docs and then type in PSO caching, you'll
find the correct documentation page on exactly the step by step process of how to set that
up for your scenes.